while Zuckerberg was on Capitol Hill
Gayle spoke with another big-name in
Silicon Valley Tesla CEO Elon Musk let's
go back to Gayle in Washington
hi Gayle hello John that's right we were
in California on Tuesday Tesla CEO Elon
Musk knows that the future of his
electric car company depends on his
ability to mass-produce quality
affordable cars but he also admits he's
fallen way behind on the production
goals for the popular Model 3 so on
Tuesday we went to Fremont California
that's where the Tesla factory is and we
asked Elon Musk about the hundreds of
thousands of people who put down
thousand-dollar deposits and still have
not received those cars should customers
be worried should they be worried about
what's happening with their Model 3 and
when they will get their Model 3 it's
it's best to look at this not in an
exact numerical way but in it on a
calendar basis this shouldn't get
question mark as to whether somebody's
going to get their car it's just yes
you'll definitely get your car it's
gonna be six nine much longer than
expected are you saying people don't
really need to be worried this is a
little hiccup right now it's a six to
nine month time shift that's literally
it and three of those months have
already passed
have you had many cancellations of the
model three people frustrated by the
long way it's what most of the people
cancel because you know they just needed
a car and we didn't have a car for them
but do you feel Elon Musk personally a
lot of pressure and a big burden on your
shoulders because so many people believe
in this product believe in this company
because of you because of you okay well
I will help the faith is not misplaced
well tomorrow on CBS this morning we'll
share more of our interview with Elon
Musk he will give us the first-ever look
inside the model 3 production line you
see it there and explain why its
production delays have been worse than
expected guys he has answers for all of
this he as he's very confident he knows
he's under the gun you know the waiting
list has over 400,000 people on it who
have each put down $1,000 and they want
those cars mmm it's interesting
shareholders will be watching that
interview closely that the stocks taken
a hit over the past few months over
those concerns so it's important to hear
from them now Gail thanks for looking
forward to it